[Musica]
abbiamo già sentito in questa sala
parlare di cibo del futuro e le meduse
sono state nominate come cibo del futuro
io vorrei dire che però il futuro è già
qui probabilmente come dice gibson
dobbiamo distribuirlo un pò meglio
perchè perchè attualmente
dall'interazione fra la ricerca
scientifica e l'industria l'avvio
industria abbiamo già sul mercato dei
cibi tradizionali dei cibi fortificati
con attività nutraceutica funzionali
in realtà quello di cui noi parliamo
adesso è the novel food quelli che per
l'europa sono definiti novel food cioè
tutti quei cibi che non sono stati
consumati in maniera significativa in
europa prima del 97 ed è importante dire
questo perché questo range di cibi e
regolamentato da leggi europee e leggi
che sono state di recente anche
aggiornate e in questo aggiornamento
sono stati inclusi quei cibi che sono
cibi nuovi per l'europa ma che sono cibi
tradizionali da millenni dei paesi terzi
effettivamente le meduse sono un cibo
tradizionale molto gradito
molto valutato in cina da millenni
appunto tuttavia guardando un po nella
letteratura e ho potuto vedere che anche
nel ricettario più antico d epoca romana
apicio celio cita una ricetta in cui
parla di un piatto di acciughe senza
acciughe in cui aggiunge urti cas
marinas che probabilmente una medusa che
aggiunge per camuffare il cile il sapore
tanto ad mensa ma nessuno saprà che cosa
ha mangiato
perché in effetti c'è per noi una
repulsione verso questo animale da
utilizzare come come cibo
questo è dovuto in parte ad motivi
culturali ma probabilmente anche a
motivi biologici c'è un fenomeno che la
neofobia alimentare cioè la paura dei
cibi nuovi che comunque è un fenomeno
positivo perché ci preserva
biologicamente ci preserva
dall'avvelenamento di cibi sconosciuti e
e quindi c'è una esperienza ripetuta che
ci porta poi all'abitudine alimentare
qual è il tempo che porta
dall'esperienza all'abitudine qui stiamo
vedendo per esempio dei cibi che sono
assolutamente tradizionali per noi la
pizza la polenta fanno parte della dieta
mediterranea che è patrimonio
dell'unesco
ma se pensiamo alla cir i tradizionali
nel 1500 in italia quali erano nessuno
di questi perché prima del 1492 cioè
prima della scoperta dell'america non
c'era nessuno di questi prodotti primari
e quindi possiamo concludere che la
dieta mediterranea patrimonio
intangibile dell'umanità non è altro che
frutto di una migrazione di popoli e di
prodotti detto questo
ritorniamo al fatto che le abitudini
alimentari dipendono essenzialmente da
diversi fattori culturali biologici ma
di fatto dipendono dalla presenza o meno
di risorse naturali e delle
disponibilità di queste risorse per le
popolazioni se parliamo di risorse
the marine dobbiamo confermare quello
che è stato detto cioè che il pescato la
quantità di pescato si sta riducendo di
anno in anno è stato calcolato che in 50
anni il numero di specie quindi la
biodiversità marina si è ridotta del 30
per cento e la prospettiva è che nel
2050 tutte le attività di pesca saranno
annullate
contemporaneamente quello che si sta
osservando quello che gli scienziati
stanno osservando che c'è un aumento
della proliferazione delle meduse
qui se guardate le regioni costiere
colorate in arancio e in rosso
potete verificare che nella maggior
parte delle zone costiere si osserva un
aumento delle popolazioni di medusa e
quindi è in corso un cambiamento degli
ecosistemi marini in cui sia una
riduzione dei pesci di grossa taglia ed
un aumento dello zooplancton gelatinoso
cioè praticamente delle meduse con
l'idea che in un futuro i nostri oceani
saranno potranno essere abitati da
medusa e da animali organismi che
mangiano le meduse
ovviamente in questa situazione oltre ad
un impatto sugli ecosistemi marini sia
un impatto sulle attività umane ed in
effetti c'è un grosso impatto sul
turismo sulla sull'industria per esempio
si è verificato in diversi paesi il
blocco di centrali elettriche o di
centrali nucleari per l'intasamento a
causa di meduse dei sistemi di
raffreddamento di questi impianti e
soprattutto un impatto sull'acqua
cultura e sulla pesca
questa è una immagine proprio della
nostra puglia dove c'è una sola immagine
di pescatori che tornano al porto con le
reti
nelle barche piene di meduse piuttosto
che di pesce e hanno trascorso poi tutta
la mattinata a liberare le reti dalle
meduse e non hanno avuto nessun tipo di
reddito da questo hanno avuto una
perdita economica notevole se avessero
potuto utilizzare questo materiale come
come prodotto ittico
ovviamente sarebbe stato diverso
e questa è un'altra zona della nostra
puglia e ginosa marina
questo video è stato girato l'anno
scorso ma vi posso assicurare che
quest'anno nella stessa situazione ci
sono tonnellate di di meduse abbiamo
calcolato con delle riprese aeree con
delle immersioni subacquee che ci sono
in quella zona fino a 800 tonnellate di
meduse questa è la rizzo stoma pulmo a
questo punto quindi noi possiamo
scegliere o continuare a considerare
questo come un danno una un danno al
turismo un problema oppure pensare di
utilizzarlo utilizzarlo per esempio come
risorsa naturale nella
nell'alimentazione magari in un sistema
di economia circolare in cui si riduce
il
i rifiuti e si utilizzano meglio si
sfruttano meglio le risorse naturali
in effetti la pesca e l'acquacoltura di
meduse già presente in nel mondo ma
soprattutto nei paesi del sud est
asiatico ed e si tratta come vedete di
un'attività di un'economia di
sussistenza sono impiegate soprattutto
le donne
per esempio in thailandia sono girate le
donne durante la bassa stagione della
pesca al granchio e ma anche in in
america in georgia in particolare la
crisi della pesca al gambero ha portato
i pescherecci a dedicarsi alla pesca
della cannon ball jellyfish l'ala questa
medusa che viene poi essiccata sul posto
e spedita nel mercato nel sud est
asiatico mercato che è molto florido
perché i numeri sono della fao ma sono
assolutamente sottostimati
ci sono c'è un giro d'affari di migliaia
di dollari per produzioni molto elevate
e quindi a questo punto vale la pena
pensare di utilizzare le meduse come una
risorsa economica anche perché l'abbiamo
già detto
l'impatto ecologico di fonti di proteine
terrestri sta diventando sempre pesante
sappiamo che un chilo di carne di bovino
produce 60 kg di co2 mentre uno di
mitili ne produce solo 10 probabilmente
le meduse ancora meno
dobbiamo però verificare che questo cibo
sia adeguato da un punto di vista
nutrizionale e per questo l'europa e
molto attenta questo a questo problema e
ha finanziato un progetto che si chiama
go gelli in cui il cn
i spa di lecce ha proprio il ruolo di
verificare che dalle meduse possano
essere prodotti in maniera coerente con
le leggi europee gli alimenti o
ingredienti alimentari
oppure composti bioattivi in effetti la
nostra attività e la produzione di
composti bioattivi per l'industria
nutraceutica cosmetica e farmaceutica e
la produzione di alimenti magari gli
eventi funzionali che siano però
adeguati al mercato europeo
in effetti le caratteristiche delle
siamo studiando le principali e meduse
del del mediterraneo come tutte le
meduse sono costituite prevalentemente
di acqua ma quel 5 per cento di materia
secca è costituito essenzialmente da
proteina e di queste proteine la
principale circa l'ottanta per cento e
collagene e il collagene una proteina
che ha un valore commerciale perché
attualmente viene estratto da animali
terrestri con rischi seri per quanto
riguarda la biesse ma anche da residui
del pesce e quindi potrebbe essere una
buona fonte di una di una proteina
commercialmente valida le
caratteristiche di queste specie di
meduse sono molto interessanti e una
proteina con attività antiossidante
molto elevata composti bioattivi hanno
un basso contenuto di lipidi e questi
lipidi hanno un rapporto mega 3 omega6
ottimale
quest'attività riscuote molto successo
noi l'abbiamo presentata ad expo e
adesso abbiamo lasciato ai
professionisti della cucina la
possibilità di con la loro creatività di
creare dei piatti adeguati alla al
pubblico europeo italiano perché abbiamo
fatto una gelatina di acqua
pomodoro quindi per stemperare un po
anche qui la stabilità e su cui abbiamo
messo di suoi stati stagione
entriamo in un piatto che è stato molto
apprezzato anche dai nostri colleghi
stranieri quindi concludendo le
abitudini alimentari sono in continuo
cambiamento magari adesso è un po più
veloce questo cambiamento è dovuto a
cambiare a migrazioni cambiamenti nella
società ma anche adesso a cambiamenti
climatici dobbiamo soltanto a decidere
come utilizzare questo cambiamento
probabilmente la cultura popolare può
può darci una mano oltre che la scienza
ha detto come questo parlatore nel
riempie la padella d'acqua allora la
prima bollita segue sì ho prima bollita
e dovetti diventata talmente rigida
hanno tagliato a fette della beta
infarinata
primo giorno l'ho fatta solo infarinata
e fritta secondo giorno ho fatto
infarinata con le uova e pane
grattugiato
comunque la squisita e poi nel piatto si
presenta in un modo bellissimo non è
come tante altre cose delle strane di
mare non proprio tu vedendo la invita a
mangiarla ecco questo per due tre giorni
molto alla prossima volta magari la
parola
[Musica]